par hasard j'ai trouvé un cancer du
cancer du Rhin où on m'a on m'a opéré on
fait on m'a ouvert parce que j'avais
trop de veines sur le sur les raids et
cetera mais c'est guéri alors ce que je
voulais dire c'est que tous les
problèmes que j'ai eu de santé ils sont
guéris j'ai eu un prêt diabète j'ai une
prostatite j'ai eu le cancer et c'est et
je tenais dans le bouquet à le dire
parce qu'il y a des gens à qui on
annonce aujourd'hui qu'ils ont un cancer
c'est un mot qui fait peur tu comprends
rien moi je veux leur dire regardez je
suis guéri ça se guérit ces choses-là
mais ça se guérit aussi avec avec le
mental tu sais à quel point le moral est
important dans tout ça le mental m'a
vachement aidé et puis j'ai eu la
séparation avec Nana alors justement
tu parles de ta séparation avec Nathalie
avec qui je suis resté plus rester plus
de 30 ans avec elle mais je suis
toujours allé à côté avec moi là vous
êtes restés non mais parce que ça aussi
j'essaie d'expliquer qu'on peut séparer
sans se déchirer sans s'insulter sans en
protégeant les gamins on a une vie
sentimentale
séparés mais on bosse ensemble on est
amis etc donc toutes ces choses là c'est
pour expliquer à ceux qui passent par
ces épreuves là et je sais si j'en ai
ramassé là pendant deux ans et ben qu'on
peut s'en sortir avec un peu plus de de
bienveillance de tolérance et puis de
l'optimisme justement tu dis je fête la
Saint-Valentin avec moi-même en guise de
cœur qui bat le mien ralenti ou
s'accélère au rythme de l'effet des
antidouleurs la séparation de mon couple
c'est juxtaposée avec l'invasion du
crabe tout est arrivé en même temps tout
est arrivé en même temps mais bon c'est
la vie c'est comme ça tu sais j'ai eu
pire j'ai eu la mort de mon fils et ce
jour là ma maman m'a dit c'est pas la
fin de quelque chose c'est le début
d'autre chose et je prends tout comme ça
aujourd'hui et j'essaie de donner de
cette force que j'ai eu à tout le monde
ça fait partie de la et surtout ne pas
s'apitoyer et ne pas se plaindre je me
plains de rien c'est des événements de
la vie c'est autre chose qui démarre que
je vis très bien j'ai gambadé tout l'été
sur les scènes je vais en profiter au
passage je veux passer deux messages
d'abord au minot j'ai un nouveau public
c'est des entre 15 et 22 ans qui sautent
sur des chansons qui les connaissent par
coeur et je vais passer aussi un message
à mes copines ça j'ai promis de le faire
on dit tu diras à Nouna que la seule
musique qui vaut c'est le métal
ah d'accord donc c'était avec des
copines du métal en ce moment mais on
les embrasse aussi bien sûr
ce bouquin aussi pour ça pour dire que
tu prends tous les gens tous les jours
tous ceux qui sont là tu prends des
trucs dans la gueule tu prends des des
maladies tu prends des des ruptures tu
prends des excréments
j'ai toujours une réaction j'ai refait
ce que j'avais fait la première fois la
première personne que j'ai croisé j'ai
dit [ __ ] on vient de m'annoncer un
truc c'est un signe astrologique je sais
plus lequel Capricorne scorpion ah non
cancer c'est ça quand même me dire parce
que un petit peu du monde c'est pas de
mal j'ai pris ça comme une maladie
comment il faut savoir aujourd'hui que
ça se guérit aussi bon quand tu l'as
appris tu dis parce que c'est arrivé une
période comme tu le dis Patrick c'est
vrai que moi je te dis tout moi c'est
vrai que à un moment
je sais que chez plutôt de tes nouvelles
on m'avait dit ouais Patrick pour
l'instant Patrick il faut le laisser un
peu voilà mais il y a tout qui s'enquit
et puis tu te bats quoi et puis je te
dis j'ai connu des des trucs tellement
plus violents cancers c'est un cancer
c'est la vie quoi je veux dire c'est ça
arrive ça arrive à plein de gens là je
suis du bol j'appelle ça un chancer
d'ailleurs parce qu'on me l'a trouvé par
hasard les trucs j'ai commencé bah j'ai
fait une écho de contrôle pour rien et
puis j'ai un toubib formidable qui qui
m'a qui m'a dit à une tâche blanche là
tu devrais faire une IRM tu me fais pas
chier je suis claustro et puis il a
insisté fait une biopsie et ça donne la
phrase la plus surréaliste comme toubibi
à son patient quand je dis que c'est un
cancer il m'a dit mais je suis bien
content je suis bien content oui je suis
bien content de t'avoir poussé à faire
des investigations donc n'hésitez pas
allez vous faire contrôler parce que
c'était une tumeur non invasive ça m'est
installe il suffit d'enlever si on le
sait assez tôt
il faut juste dire aux gens faites-vous
contrôler allez regarder et donc ce truc
là
en coulisses avec moi il est ici aussi
je sais et Patrick là c'est
tout ce qui est arrivé après tu dis
voilà le premier truc qui m'est arrivé
c'est cette évolution de la télévision
c'est vrai que voilà tu es violent ça a
été violent c'est est-ce que tu penses
que c'est c'est ça aussi qui a fait
qu'après tu as eu tu sais tu as changé
avec de tous les trucs comme ça sont
liés à des problèmes de santé le stress
ça crée ça c'est les contrariétés moi je
sais qu'après le mélanome que j'avais eu
c'était après la mort de ma mère donc
c'est quelque chose auquel je
m'attendais à avoir un truc physique
je croise les doigts je m'en fous tu
l'avais dit à tes proches tu l'avais dit
que je sens que tu vas avoir un truc
parce que ça m'a trop pas tu le sens
forcément quand tu regardes tous les
gens qui ont eu des deuils de proches il
se déclenche des trucs derrière
forcément obligatoirement ça va avec le
mental encore une fois et le stress sont
plus important mais encore une fois si
tu te plains et si tu tapis toi et si tu
te dis tu vois tu en veux au sort tu
dises pas normal etc tu t'en sors pas
c'est comme ça alors il y a il y a un
passage très fort dans le livre où tu
dis je ne te cache pas qu'il est tentant
le 9 mm là tout près dans le tiroir de
l'armoire d'en face [ __ ] comme souvent
j'en ai envie il suffirait d'un nylon et
boom sans peur et sans regret l'acide
tout à leur boum une balle dans la tête
pour accoster de mon plein gré avant le
naufrage j'ai pas les couilles pas pour
l'instant tout simplement parce que je
n'en ai pas les couilles ouais mais
pardon pour la grossirtine mais j'écris
des mots comme ils viennent le suicide
est un acte de courage pas une lâcheté
ouais parce que en fait j'ai toujours
été comme ça ça y est je me suis
toujours dit j'ai pas choisi le moment
où j'arrivais j'aimerais bien choisir le
moment où je pars mais pas je me je veux
pas j'ai pas envie de me flinguer de
désespoir c'est pas ça c'est que j'ai eu
un bol énorme malgré les les douleurs
sur j'ai eu j'ai une chance énorme de
vivre une vie fascinante extraordinaire
alors j'ai un peu une métaphore dans le
bouquin je dis j'ai bouffé j'ai une vie
où j'ai bouffé du caviar du champagne je
vais pas finir avec une madeleine
pourrie une compote pourrie quoi moi
j'ai vu ma mère ce traîner d'hôpitaux en
hôpitaux pendant quatre ans je veux pas
ça moi si je peux m'arrêter avant
pourquoi tu as pensé
je suis sur scène que je suis vivant
parce que là je suis vraiment vivant
j'ai des projets partout tout va bien
mais la déchéance physique et mentale
surtout c'est un truc que j'aurais
vachement de mal accepté ouais ouais ça
serait un truc que j'aurais vachement de
mal accepté mais il faudrait pas être
triste pour moi parce que ça serait
quelque chose que j'ai voulu que j'ai
mais sera triste je te le dis mais le
plus tard
j'ai pas envie mais c'est horrible
j'ai toujours pensé à ça toujours je
suis toujours moi c'est un truc que j'ai
toujours moi la vie la mort m'ont
toujours passionné c'est c'est un chemin
qui est merveilleux la mort c'est
fabuleux c'est le seul moment où on est
tous égaux tous qui conçoit quel que
soit notre fortune quel que soit notre
beauté
je la souhaite pas aux toilettes aussi
on est toujours à ça
elle viendra parce que c'est lucide
aussi tu dis j'ai 68 balais tu regardes
autour de toi des qui tombe chez des
copains qui sont tombés à 66 67
peut-être que je vais vivre je vais
revenir dans 20 ans ici tu seras vieux
tu feras encore ton émission ils sont
tous là pas tous
ils seront plus là on essaye de qui on
veut parler voilà mais bon
voilà il y a autre chose importante dans
le bouquin c'est ma manière de penser
c'est que tout est écrit pour moi moi je
fais partie des gens qui pensent que
tout est écrit qu'on a un karma et sur
c'est pas la peine de lutter contre
l'inéluctable puisque ça doit arriver
tu seras faucher
la rencontre avec Jeff elle devait
arriver alors on s'est rencontré par
hasard c'était un hasard le jour où je
viens de voir je peux être complètement
ailleurs ça a été un déclencheur je
pense que les choses doivent arriver
sont alors quand on pense comme ça on se
met moins en colère contre les contre
les coups du sort on se dit mais voilà
ça devait arriver c'est là maintenant
essayons de gérer et je maintiens encore
une fois quitte à passer pour un
bisounours que quand tu restes dans la
bienveillance quand tu restes dans le
regard vers les autres quand tu regardes
la générosité et ben tu t'en sors mieux
que les hommes Gilbert ils s'en sort
très bien tu évoques également l'argent
à la télé mais tu rapportes ça la
prostitution
je me suis dit que ce n'est pas un sujet
tabou pour toi je n'ai aucun état d'âme
par rapport aux sommes que m'a rapporté
la télévision c'est le salaire justifié
de toute prostitution bah oui plus de
luxe chacun sur son bout de trottoir on
met en valeur nos avantages on a Guichon
raffolent et plus le client est content
et puis il paye c'est incroyable
c'est ça c'est vrai que c'est un peu ça
tu considère les animateurs comme des
prostituées de luxe hein tu considères
les animateurs comme des prostituées
on vend nos armes
ben oui on va on va on va au notre cam
quoi notre Kaamelott on essaie de
charmer on essaie de séduire et puis si
le client est content ben on continue
voilà si l'image mais c'est vrai c'est
une chanson à l'époque qui s'appelait
garçon de joie alors es-tu
[Applaudissements]